what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
Richie is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do go in there having
fun then get out okay okay then then get
out then get out faster Esther then get
out I'm not here to get canceled today
most men want a woman that has some
degree of femininity where they feel
like they're taking care of taking care
of I'm a lady like I'm submissive and
you'll be surprised because I will say
what I want to say now and I'll say well
I want to say with my mind but my
demeanor doesn't change and I'm going to
look down on him because at the end of
the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened to
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I would feel so so bad asking
a guy to buy like a three thousand
dollar bag
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and as that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams
um a couple announcements before we
start the show I'm the first guys if you
have any questions you want me to ask
the panel make sure you send a Super
Chat tonight we're also going to do a
special
Super Chat allowance if you want to have
anyone's my commuted for five minutes
you donate a hundred dollars and we'll
mute anyone's mic for five minutes don't
abuse it though okay don't I'm trusting
you guys don't go crazy with this like
they're here to talk but for a hundred
bucks yeah five minutes
um also guys make sure
um you subscribe to our two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
also we have four membership tiers King
how many La how many likes to open up
the chat today
okay a thousand five hundred likes to
open up the chat today
um also what are we blessing what are we
don't don't show them yet what are we
what are we saving for now
okay we want to kick out cam so if you
guys want to see a kick out cam make
sure you send super Chats on for a kick
out camera also guys um I think we're
gonna do a meet up sometime this month I
know I've been gaslighting you guys for
a minute I swear we are going to do one
soon so make sure you sign up for our
Google form so you are notified when we
do
um also guys make sure you go subscribe
to our talents Auntie Jenny King Richie
King riches and Amiri and the most
important announcement today
is that blessing is coming on camera so
drum roll please everybody a blessing
reveal all right
[Applause]
introducing blessings
[Laughter]
blessing what what made you come out of
hiding today
no we could have done three we've done
three before don't don't act like you
were you were forced all right yeah you
know it's about time you know it's about
time you came out uh you came out of
hiding yeah what have you what have you
noticed from the show so far from
watching these shows I love the
delusional women out there yeah
you guys know you guys wow hopefully no
you guys yeah yeah well we're gonna talk
about that today um
start we're
your age your relationship status in a
fun fact so um starting here and then go
around a fun fact I don't have one I
mean it could just be about you you got
a hobby what's your Hub you got any
hobbies
um I like shopping my name's
sharon27 and yeah I love shopping
relationship state is single wait
oh and you can plug any Instagrams too
if you want to do that you're welcome
too
where's my Instagram
shopping cool
XOXO
that's it all right is it yeah go ahead
hi guys my name is Tuffy Jean I'm an
upcoming rap star
purine today I'm going to be doing some
crazy stuff but I'm 28 I'm 26 years old
I'm a mother and I'm currently in a
complicated relationship
situationship I don't know what it is
you're gonna find is this is this with
the father of yours is it how many kids
I got two kids two kids and you're in a
situationship situationship with him why
it's getting pretty rough patch at the
moment but I'm just praying things get
better that's a whole different board
game that is situationship boy I just
imagine now that there's kids involved
like you gotta you gotta stay together
instead of the situation if only that
was the case because like with me I've
got three myself oh you have three
children as well for you myself but
sometimes you know as much as you would
like for your relationship to work out
with your children's father it just
doesn't makes it so what's stopping you
guys a lot a lot like what
no comment they'll be exposing them okay
you don't have to you don't have to go
into detail I just I just wonder when
you have kids involved like what what
stops two people from being together
should just behave themselves what do
you what do you mean
no matter how much you do for them but
they just want to be dogs oh they're
like they're cheating you mean yeah come
here doggy they go running to anyone do
you have an open Instagram account
yeah okay so how are we gonna like judge
men for the cheating when most of us
have opened Instagrams
I made mine open after
[Music]
years after otherwise it was private and
now I'll just do whatever I do me okay
what about you well mine is public
because I am an artist yeah so I have to
have it public yeah but my point is more
of the double standards right because
it's like women actively get attention
from men you guys are pretty girls like
you know you're pretty girls so it's
like anytime we have an open Instagram
we're actively getting attention from
men and any man can message you and so
it's like it's like often yeah I
understand that but it's like oftentimes
we judge men for Cheating in a
relationship but we cheat every day by
having open social medias by accepting
attention from men that are not our
husbands but the fact that they are the
ones our men are the ones missing the
girls yeah a bit you know so they are
cheating they're the ones cheating yeah
but if you're accepting the messages
like I think it's equally yeah I agree
with that yeah yeah I do that part is
that your problem too the dogness you
know I don't know no comments no comment
okay okay you don't have to blessing you
want to do a fun fact yeah
so blessing producer of the just fairly
things poured I like to stay behind the
scenes in a relationship
so so question
um for you guys do you guys consider
yourselves traditional women no no no
okay do you guys want traditional
relationships or no no okay so you're
good with the 50s you want 50 50 the
bills a 100 100
50. I'm saying what do you mean you're
both paying 100 you want to live in
separate houses
oh yeah
I just want to know how this is gonna
how is this gonna work
well how is this gonna work
I don't put this oh no
yeah okay you know what it should be 50
50 right it should be
oh actually right now for me the comment
for me it should be hundred hundred
because you know they expect the woman
to be at home looking after the kids and
also work also work from my point of
view you have to work as well you know
they put that pressure on you for you to
go to work because they're not the
building's not making sense zombie
Housewives right yeah some be Housewives
but I'm talking like from my point of
view you know I mean like in my
situation I'm working I'm also looking
after the kids I'm doing everything do
you get what I mean but he just goes to
work comes back um so you both work
basically okay but it's like when it
comes to the children so who watches the
kids when you you're at work you have to
go to Nursery oh they go to they go to
daycare now they're grown now but before
that I was doing slowly you're 20 so how
old are your kids
I've got cheer on a six-year-old oh
they're not grown they aren't grown
my daughter is 10 so I've got three like
I said my oldest is ten she'll be 11
this year not looking forward to it at
all and then I've got an eight-year-old
and an almost two-year-old yeah crazy
the youngest Rebel so Red Bull so I I
have a question for you
um how because I always wonder this like
with like people that send their kids to
Nursery do you worry about them having
more influence on your children than you
will I do yeah but at the same time it's
like if I have to sacrifice something to
gain something you know if if that a
home with me
I can't put food on the table yeah as
well you know I don't wanna have to deal
with the extra garbage and the stress
and all so however work you know baby go
to Nursery or spend time with you when
you come back home if you're tired it's
okay weekend I'll try and make some time
for you and you guys couldn't survive
off of one income is what you're saying
okay especially you know like the whole
covered and everything is it was just
ridiculous and having to move to
Birmingham it's cool ridiculous so why
um I think blessing joined the show
because you said something about Zim
culture you're not a fan of I'm against
him so what what do you not like about
this you're gonna have them coming from
my nap
this is about to get heated where did
you marry Zimbabwe no I would never date
or marry a Zimbabwe and I've never dated
as a mother man I never will look at one
why
they are just
yeah why I was just leave it there let
me not say anything to me they say if
you don't have nothing anything nice to
say don't say anything at all right is
that because of an ex or no it's just I
don't really want to put my past too
much into this but it's just the way I
was raised you know my father is
obviously Zimbabwean and the things are
women you're dead to a certain extent
but I love him now
why now
because I feel like he's paying for
everything he's on to me
what
did he what did he do
well when I was young well not too young
when I was like 17 years old he did
throw me out
and that really hurt
it threw me out because of his wife
that's not my mom
and I was going through so much trauma
I was very suicidal in that time and I
felt like I was shut up
and what what caused you to get thrown
out like was it a fight it was a petty
fight that
paused
that caused me to get for now and you
had no part to play in the fight
I did say something that was wrong okay
now that I look back
because I was trying to find out about
my mom you know I used to ask him about
my mom oh tell me about my mom and he
was just say you know she left you and
that didn't sit right with me because
the fact with my mom was telling me
different you know so I just wanted to
know from him like you're my father tell
me about her and
that day even though he was so angry at
me I'm gonna explain everything that
happened in the moment but he was so
angry to the point where I said you're
trying to kick me out just like you did
to my mom and that's what made him
really get extremely angry and I was not
wrong I was right yeah but the way you
tell the story you act like it was all
him and nothing like you didn't do
anything and this prose I feel like I
blazing myself like yeah you have a part
to play yeah like everyone does I should
have never said anything to him
but but do you think it was time for me
to say something because that whole you
know mental abuse from
his wife and him it was too much like
mental abuse I'm not gonna explain
exactly everything because I don't need
to say that you know but there's certain
things that
have put me through even from when I was
younger well it's just like mentally
that's like a pretty severe accusation
you know it was yeah it was really bad
but I don't want to stay because I know
if certain people see this they don't
like that so and so because he but
because he kicked out he kicked you out
at 17 in a fight that you guys like both
had a part to plan would you admit now
she created it you said you would you
shouldn't have said anything right I
shouldn't have said anything to him
actually just kept it directly to her
because she was the one that had an
issue with me
the whole time but because he acted out
of anger based on whatever he told him
in that moment he was angry at me and I
was also angry I had the right to say
whatever I say you know I'm only human
you think you have the right to say
anything because you're angry I mean I
didn't swear at him
yeah you know that's disrespectful and
my point is that but if it was if
someone is shoving you out the house and
bringing things out the window what are
you gonna do what are you everything
yeah you're not gonna stand you're not
gonna stand there you cannot everything
just kind of came to me like wow so the
way you threw my mom out is exactly the
same way you're doing to me wait did
this happen here or in Zimbabwe in the
UK
well with her yeah with her yeah in the
UK but why is it like a zoom culture's
fault if it's just your situation
because all the men in my family are
trash
yeah all of them but I think it's as
well that she's been through a lot when
it comes to like the men in her family
so it's just made her
think that way
no I mean I I know
um like grape victims that don't view
men a certain way like you can go
through things like that's like saying
if one guy got cheated on by a woman and
saying all women cheat
so it's like you're throwing out an
entire culture what I mean by
certain people have come across us oh I
was involved with and have really tried
to torment my life for me sounds like uh
you feel like the common denominator it
sounds like a respect issue because
they're 17 and I've got siblings who are
Zimbabwean and I know like a zim
household is is built on respect
respecting the illnesses respecting
their parents would you say in that
situation where you were respectful to
your parents How can I
not say anything so you wanted me to
keep shutting myself out keep taking
pills to do essay on myself like
literally to commit suicide you wanted
me to carry and do that instead of me
speaking out that was the first time
I've ever spoken out to my dad yeah but
what did she do that was so like
insanely better she was angry she was
going through her own personal issues
obviously she's got whatever she needs
to take for to help her out with her
mental health I understand that now
then they never told me that they never
told me that she had an issue with her
mental health and that's the reason why
she used to treat me really badly you
know there's been so many things that's
happened between me and her to the point
where she even warned me that she wanted
to get rid of me she told me how old did
you like your dad have like a bring it
in
um I think from like 15 was it 15 when I
left slow
no your turn
yeah 15. do you not think it's like um a
teenage kind of like just teenage
emotions because it sounds to me like
you just lashing out like you know my
mom and she was just not having that my
mother was dead from when I was 10 years
old so that's got nothing to do with my
mother
that's a step move on yeah I know it's a
stepmother but when she's coming into a
roof like
literally becoming like a mother in the
house she never treated me like her
daughter she told me I'm not you're not
my daughter I'll never call me
mom
oh damn and I tried to buy her love
because I never really had love from any
of the women that were in my father's
life
I would do the most I'll buy gifts I'll
I'll cook this I'll clean this do you
know what I mean what was your
relationship with your dad before that
it was amazing so why didn't you find
like like you could communicate with
them why didn't you not do that it's
really because of her um I don't know
it's like what I hear though because I
had no part to play in it and it's sort
of like a victim mentality it's like
they did everything wrong I did nothing
wrong but they that's the that's the
part though they did do wrong to me they
might have done wrong but I just think
in most situations like you can look
back and say I had a part to play when
your dad play when I was younger than
them and they're grown adults I mean I I
can you know I'll use it but try not no
I know yeah
I'm saying when I when I was a kid like
I didn't think I absolutely did things
that contributed to say that you have no
accountability just because you're
underage like that's the silliest thing
I've ever heard I I absolutely did
things that contributed to fights with
my parents okay for example let's say
you come back from college right and a
long day I'll totally cook this okay
fine I'll cook it I'll clean this I'll
cook it I clean it I do have a house
she's telling me to do right
just one thing I forgot to do bear in
mind I've got work to do as well I've
got homework to do I've done everything
she said I need to do oh but you forgot
to do this yeah but that's just typical
that's just typical yeah but what she
would do she would not create the issue
from that yeah oh can you imagine she
never did this and she'll purposely mess
up the yard let's mess up the house and
make it seem like I didn't do anything
that's that's what I started thinking
that right that's a bit weird now that's
crazy that is weird and the part when
she thought I was dressing up in a
specific way for my father who said same
to me I was dressing up for my father
that's that's why I was like no there's
something wrong with her but then my dad
never told me like oh she's got a mentor
issue but if he did I probably would
have understood like okay you know what
maybe let me be a bit more sensitive let
me not feel some type of way when she
does certain things but because he never
did and all the time she touched me you
know beating me and all that stuff
police code and everything
that wouldn't have happened if there was
certain things put in place for her not
to even react like that towards me
because I don't understand why the angle
was so much towards me yeah this story
is just this story just seems very crazy
like it's like so she was messing up the
yard and then it was we like it was so
back to the point where I started
feeling like you know when you get to a
point where you say you know what I'm
done and then you're like taking pills
because you're like I've had enough and
the person is telling you I'm gonna I'm
gonna do something to you like they're
taking certain things I'm not gonna say
what it is but
and then you're there standing in the
Church of praising God and the person is
looking at you giving you like dirty
looks I didn't feel comfortable anywhere
I wouldn't accept College literally at
school literally
so I bro you know when your dad brought
it over do you guys have like a meeting
like oh I'm gonna bring this woman over
it's gonna pretty much become like a
mother in the house was I ever like that
discussion yeah he told me that he's
seeing someone and everything and I was
really excited and when she first came I
was so happy I was oh my God I finally
have a mom now yeah how did that first
like encounter like how was that for me
I was happy because I felt like I'm
gonna have a mom I'm gonna have a mom
because of it's in my mom's sister
obviously I broke up and my dad bought I
was like okay at least now I have
someone that can go to you know because
there's certain things that was
happening to me when I was growing up
you know the feminine stuff I can't talk
to my dad about it so I was happy that
she was coming into the picture you know
I really loved that now when I found out
she had kids and stuff like that I was
like oh my God this is really did you
guys live with the kids as well haircuts
no her kids aren't back home
all right so how how did how was their
reaction like meeting you at first it
was good but I know when it's the the
shift happened when she felt pregnant
do you know things it's just emotions
female emotions when they're pregnant I
I was I was trying
supposed to know that oh okay she's
acting like this because she's pregnant
and she also got a certain issue if
someone spoke to me and said okay she's
acting like this and not being blamed
for my brother my Step Brothers do not
losing my step brother is
it's a bit I just think like it's just
hard for me to believe on the outside
looking in that your mom had a problem
with you or yourself sorry sorry sorry
stepmom stepmom had a problem with you
your dad had a problem with you and like
my dad never had an issue to the end
yeah I know but if he's kicking you out
it just seems like you probably had a
part to play like it doesn't seem like
you should demonize all Zimbabwe men
yeah that was kind of a cultural problem
that is a cultural problem because
I know I know a little bit like a little
stepmom's a step stepdads families that
get along my my friend is as a stepmom
and they pretty much get along so I
don't know how it's like a zoom issue
because my problem now is like you going
with the narrative like oh Zim Mana like
this when we are not over like this and
the couch is not like this the couch is
built on family but what happens at law
is when people go into like the West
coming from Zimbabwe let's put on
Secrets no there's no family it's all
secretive everyone keeps everything
hidden no no you won't try to pretend
do you think children are entitled for a
parent is able to do you think a parent
should be able to explain them so to a
child I think so yes
you have to explain yourself did not um
why okay why no I think that's a must
because
like with my children personally right
if there's a situation I will explain to
my children like this is a situation
like dude between this person that
person depends on the situation of
course because they're still very young
but the children need to be aware
otherwise it's going to be like how it
was with her where no one told her
anything you just kept in a room
nothing I think you become westernizing
just become entitled to feel like you
that they deserve you deserve an
explanation because if a parent is
providing that is their core value like
I'm here to provide for you anything
else this is the reason why Zimbabwean
culture is I'm completely you have to be
able to speak to your child you can't
silence your children you guys do this
all the time oh Mom I'm going through
this shush oh I'm dating this boy you
can't take boys
with a bunch of whiners where it's like
this problem that problem that they used
to live through plagues like they used
to live through real problem now we have
all this trauma this mental unstability
I'm not talking about you personally but
it's like it's like and you don't
deserve an explanation from your parents
forever
you don't deserve anything I do that the
world doesn't owe you [__] the world
holds me everything
yes he does yes like the world the world
owes you nothing if you don't explain to
your children certain situations and
they can't feel comfortable coming to Ox
you think a lot of times you're better
for not knowing certain situations I
don't want to know what my parents are
fighting about I don't want to know what
my parents mental health issues are like
a lot of times you're better for not
knowing things
to be honest right now I think you guys
are so privileged your parents did you a
favor by bringing into this country
right yeah my mom did thank you Mom yeah
but you think you're dead there's
nothing to play in that room well you
had to
we had to do it yeah he's the old my mom
that at least how did it that's the
least he owed my mind
I'm not gonna explain my dad's situation
because you guys are trying to make me
experience my father I'm not gonna do
that okay but he owed my mom that he
owned my mom he owed my mom so you're
coming here and saying oh is Zimbabwean
cultures yes they are they are my
parents worked hard in a country that
right now
and bro no they don't really always they
should when he had me I didn't choose
for him to have me know so he has a
responsibility he's obligated to look
after me I'm a child yeah he is
responsibility to look after you but you
don't have a responsibility to go and
ask for questions from I can ask my
father whatever I want and he should
answer me just like my sons can ask me
questions and I'll answer them no that's
a western mentality no it's not a
western mentality that's the reason why
that SIM card don't work you like oh
it's just I'll just say how does how
does Zim culture not work it doesn't
work like I'll say okay what outcome so
so I'm guessing Zim is more traditional
right very okay okay so so it's like the
woman submits to the her husband right
whether she's she's cheating on you or
not whether he's abusing or not you stay
women are happier in traditional
outcomes every stat will tell you this
women have more STDs they're more likely
to be depressed they're more likely to
be on antidepressants they're more
likely to have had an abortion in a more
50 50 modern society in traditional
countries operate in traditional
outcomes the women are happier they're
not happy they're miserable they pretend
no they're absolutely yeah faking it
yeah
in modern culture women are in
antidepressants
women are depressed more than ever in
human history but if it's traditional
right no matter whatever culture it is
you you can't get out even if you want
to get out you can't get out because
you're gonna think oh what about my
family what would the culture say yeah
and that's and that's better because
that was when mothers put their kids
before them it wasn't a meme culture
it's not about my happiness about your
kids your kids more likely to go to
prison they're more likely to be in a
mental institution they're more likely
to drop out of school you're putting
your kid at every statistical
disadvantage you can possibly put them
at by leaving
every statistical disadvantage sometimes
but modern women don't care because they
care about their feelings and not the
kids
but sometimes it's bad to leave how who
is it better for you or the kids
so it might be better for you but that's
if in a toxic environment if you're in a
terrific relationship wrong if in a
toxic relationship it's better to leave
for body for your children and for
yourself but why are you arguing why is
the other person arguing with you women
it's it's your argument with us it's not
always us let's be realistic like you
don't have to argue back that's a choice
you have to sit there and take it to
find it nice Define abuse abuse can be
mentally physically I need you to Define
it because a lot of times women we throw
around these buzzwords that don't mean
anything anymore that guy is physically
assaulting you right it's best to say in
that marriage because it's no no there's
a physical assault is a very minority of
cases it's a minority so that's the
exception it's not the rule
please give me another example outside
of assault
there's so many okay
what is emotional abuse what is it
emotional abuses where they're
yeah like they're trying to control you
okay you can't do this you can't do that
you can't wear this you can't wait
that's that's my problem right there you
know when you come from Zim culture they
give you advice and you guys think
advice is control they give you guys
if you're gonna talk to my producer
You're Gonna Go you need to let him
spice I'm saying they come to give you
advice they've been through situations
right you have pretty much made into the
UK they they left a country where the
amount of people that live in the
country are like a small minority right
and it's a blessing to actually be able
to leave that country because of the
situation that's going on in that
country so they have all this life
advice these are people that used to
learn in difficult circumstances right
that some of them actually in Zim
culture went to war as well so they have
all that life experience they've heard
all these things like guidance pretty
much they want to give for you for your
life but you guys feel like it's control
because you want to be so liberal you
don't want to listen to your parents and
that's why I have a disagreement with
you guys because you want Western
culture because it gives you that
liberalism that I can just do whatever I
want by doing whatever you want you have
no responsibility and you have no one to
account you
like right now you don't want to be
accountable to anybody so your parents
can tell you to do something you feel
like they're controlling you
but they can't we're grown
even you were 17 when you left the house
you can advise me when I left when I got
for an hour you have to be clear with
that you have to be realistic with that
you can't just be like oh when you left
if I picked my out I've had all my stuff
if I wanted to leave yeah what would
that be going as well I was the one slip
on the buses they were but you challenge
The Authority in the house when he
marched to me kicking me out and I said
what I said I said but I said after I
when he was three months already you had
to say something to be different what
did I say I got kicked off because I
didn't move at the house at a certain
time because of her and she's got an
issue with me hovering at a certain time
because I got school anyway she
completely kicked with that whole
situation for no reason she got mad as
usual so you go okay I don't know what
she said basically because I didn't do
it at the same time she said okay in the
mornings you have to do the tour around
eight o'clock if you're in someone's
house you have to listen to their rules
but if the person is changing the times
just because they want to get you in
trouble you guys would never understand
there because you're not in the
situation anyway so I don't I don't
expect you to
step parents of um that my parents had
divorce my mum and dad are divorce my
culture is India and back from India
like my dad is from India my mom is born
here whatever right but
um
I was Minecraft story is crazy as well
like hers but that's due to my mom's
boyfriend
abusing me as well and that shows why
women shouldn't leave because it puts
their kid at risk
but you're proving my point
no she's not she's still not doing my
things
boyfriend are you guys both married well
not coming or not in a comments All
right so you guys are not married well
maybe I don't know I'm not married
it speaks to the facts
like step parents
that's the most likely person to abuse
your children is a guy that you bring
into the house that's the most likely
stat get like my mom's boyfriend when
she brought him into the house in the
beginning well what happened was
obviously my mom was doing my dad wrong
and I chose to go with my dad because my
dad and my mom both asked us like me and
my brother who we want to go with I
chose to go with my dad and then I'm the
one that took him to my Nan's house
because he had nowhere to go and I was
like let's just go to my Nan's house
because not sleeping on the road
so from there I was staying with my dad
and my dad started acting differently
towards me right and I was a kid myself
going through my parents being divorced
and he was all about my brother my
brother my brother and I'm here trying
to go to school and come back and make
sure my dad is okay right and then I
don't know what happened like why he
chose to abuse me well actually I do
know why is because I never asked my
mother a question that he wanted me to
ask because she kind of realized that my
dad was telling me what to say right so
then my dad assaulted me and I chose to
go back to my mother I went there
her boyfriend was when you say assaulted
he like what he hit you yeah and then
like multiple times yeah my grandparents
came to stop him when my granddad wasn't
home but my nan and my uncles um had to
get him off me so after that I chose to
go back to my mom's right and I'm not
gonna lie like even though my mom did my
dad wrong I was missing my mother a
little bit I was like I'm gonna put my
hand up I was missing her so I chose to
go back to
um my mom and I also thought maybe my
dad will start caring more about me like
how he did with my brother right went
there her boyfriend's moved in he was
nice in the beginning and everything you
know how it bees because they want to
you know be like oh we care about you we
care about you then slowly slowly I
started to see his true colors
and
it did not go well it did not go well I
got kicked out as well I got kicked out
at 16. I didn't want to be thrown out
but I got kicked out because of my mom's
boyfriend because she chose to listen to
her man and
um an incident happened right I'm not
going to go too much into it but
there was a thing that he wanted to
happen through me right and my mother
was going along with it I found out and
I was in a relationship at the time with
my children's father was in a
relationship with him and then they
tried to split us up because obviously
her my mom's boyfriend wanted that thing
to happen and like a sexual thing
no it wasn't a sexual thing no no no no
no no it was not a sexual thing I can
clear that now it was not a sexual thing
at all it was it was regarding
something which I don't really want to
say just in case and um is it legal do
you say it was illegal yeah actually you
can say it was illegal because I was
only 16 wasn't I yeah so I was 16 so you
can class it as a legal but I'm not
going to go too much into what it was
but um they tried to split me and my
children's father up and because it did
not work
so they tried to split you you guys you
they tried to have you guys break up
yeah because so his thing could be
successful in what he wanted
so so the the step dad could get
successful yeah he could be successful
so whatever he planned can happen but
um so he wanted to search you up with
someone else
a kind of like that button
not in this country if that makes sense
so like an arranged type marriage
I'm not gonna go into that I'm not yeah
I'm not gonna go into that at all but
basically what happens is it's like the
theme Here is like you guys don't listen
to your parents no I used to listen I
actually used to um
well when my when I okay I'll start from
the beginning when I was growing up my
brother was always the favorite right
and because he's a boy who cares he is a
boy so he was always the favorite I
always felt left out so I was always
going to my grandparents house yeah they
always like the boys exactly who cares
like my dad likes my brother like who
cares yeah so I went it's like this
victim like boohoo it's like what I was
like whatever anyways yeah yeah it
didn't bother me because I was my
grandpa's favorite so I was like how
shame but yeah you got it you gotta go
take it where you can get it yeah yeah
all right I'm getting stuff from them
you can carry on you know whatever it is
father's always loved their sons more
like come on my mom as well my mom loved
to my brother more as well but um
maybe he's just a really cool
maybe he's just a cool guy
if your sibling is your parents favorite
that's fine I don't have a problem with
that but
my brother's not a cool guy I'll put my
hand up to that he's not a queen I'm not
a cool guy no he's not if he was I would
say yeah my brother is you know we've
got a tight relationship I love my
brother he's amazing with my children I
would say that okay he's not but he's
not a cool guy so he didn't deserve
favoritism
it just seems like there's a lot of
problems here that would go better like
if we just listen to our parents so I
hope I listen to my parents
I used to listen to my parents and my
mom allowed her boyfriend
seems it also seems like it also seems
like life would be easier if families
stayed together because your mom's
boyfriend wouldn't be in that position
and maybe I'm not really talking about
you personally like I'm just talking
about in general I just think it's
better if families stay together yeah if
it does yeah it'll be better 100. it's
my dad's favorite my mom not my mom why
don't you marry your kid's father well
you should I did oh okay
you're married you never know
okay so you're not married
you know I ain't gonna need that so it
sounds like he's working it sounds like
it sounds like he's working right he's
got a job so and you're attracted to him
you two kids with him he's glove with
two kids okay everybody he's got two
other kids yeah before her before her
okay well you can't really change the
past we made the new kids with him right
yeah so why don't you why don't you get
married some people they need to change
certain things fast yeah yeah but you
probably need to change certain things I
definitely do yeah and I have changed
them so I'm just I'm just curious like
why don't you guys work on it together
we need to put more effort in I can't
work on it on myself well maybe you need
to put more effort in you know
yes but this is
yeah this is the thing it's like always
it's like kind of an arrogance like yeah
very young I can't I'm very arrogant I
can't live did you get married very
young no not Young
we've been together for eight years okay
well
it's the most important
he's not a Zimbabwe no
they'd be married by that they'll be
married before no I would not marry
Zimbabwean sorry never but it sounds
like that would be better right yeah
[Laughter]
what's the alternative you know what I
mean it's like we it's like you either
stay together as a family or you bring
random men into your kids lives or they
bring random women correct I think both
are both ways you know
um so I'm just the situation is a you
know
for someone that disses in bubbles I
would think that you're married to
another husband that you know kids just
with you but it seems like you just
ended up in a situation just like the
one before like you your circumstance
your parents circumference exactly
that's the thing I didn't want that to
happen to me but you know when you feel
like you're going you're repeating the
cycle it's like whoa yeah why didn't you
break the cycle then how can I break the
cycle I can't work on it by myself you
can only do so much you can only do uh
you know responsible for your life since
you I am responsible for my life and I
choose I can pick and choose what I want
to do for my life right yeah you chose
to break the cycle yeah and I can I can
choose to make sure that my children
don't go through certain things right so
that's what I'm gonna do if I feel like
certain things the same person you're
gonna you're gonna be today you're gonna
not put your kids through certain things
by putting them at everything about
statistical disadvantage possibly I
would rather they have a better future
now they're more like I agree
they're more likely to go to prison
I've done hundreds of these shows like
100 like I've literally interviewed
hundreds of women every woman thinks
their kid's the exception but every
adult you talk to will talk about how
much it hurt that their parents weren't
together
of course it's gonna happen it will
right but that's what I'm saying like
it's not about you guys anymore and I'm
not really even talking about you
personally I don't know you guys
situations but like the whole point is
you're dissing a culture that that talks
about keeping families together that
don't keep families together they be
you'll be aunties [__] that
uncoordinated with that Uncle different
uncles they sleep with different uncles
but they all come together and say hi I
praise the Lord I family yeah I
understand that they understand that
personal life is personal life but
family life is more important yeah I
think people need to be realistic and be
like no it's not about being able it's
about being practical for your family if
you stay with your wife you say stay
with your partner your kids have a
better chance in life okay let me ask
you a question yeah let's go if you had
a daughter right now and she got married
man yeah and he is G in another next
woman would you ask her to stay if she's
married yeah
if she's married yes that's why okay
let's say he's abusing her physically
Oscar no that's abuse physically she
should go to the police and get them
interested
Zimbabwe man I know it's about me
they they protect their family that you
wouldn't sit back and take that you know
I'll protect my family my heart that
protects me I can't I'll protect my
family yeah but if it's just cheating
without physical abuse she made that
choice to be with that person yeah if
they committed those vows in front of
God As a Christian I believe then you
should stay and work it out to come to
my my house we'll do counseling between
you two and we'll work it out but what
if he doesn't change and well she she
made that choice to be with that person
because as long as he doesn't leave
modern women modern women pet guys that
cheat they pick guys that everybody
knows cheats they pick the guys with
kids with other women and then they're
surprised when he cheats what did you
think was going to happen every month
modern okay everyone no it's the man you
pick no it's all them now it's a menu
pick Not all men cheat it's like
okay why are the men that cheat picking
you
I don't know so it says more about you
than it does about them because there's
a lot of guys that don't cheat there's a
lot of guys that are loyal if they're
not picking you then you have to ask why
oh and then let's not forget they don't
they don't pick us we've got a selection
we've got an option plenty on the table
and yeah
okay if you say that so you you came
from a step parent household and you
made the choice to put your kids into a
stepparent household where's the step
parent you
you say your partners two other kids
yeah but I chose to I chose to accept
them because I was I went through
certain things you're pretty much
putting yourself in the same situation
you made that choice I would imagine you
coming from a choice where it didn't
work out between a stepper and you were
doing one that for your children but you
made the choice to go into that same
situation and you didn't marry there's
no commitment absolutely in a way I feel
like there's nothing wrong with
accepting someone else's kids there's
nothing wrong with it there's nothing
wrong I know there's nothing wrong with
that but for you for your situation just
looking at where you're coming from why
would you make that choice because my
stepmom didn't love me so I'm going to
show love to another child and I love
them extremely but what if you if it
doesn't work out and you leave yeah and
then you leave yeah it doesn't matter
but I'll still have them in my life no
matter what I always make sure they're
okay you know it's not the same
it is it is literally the same
you're telling me if you guys break up
and he picks someone new that you're
going to have the same relationship with
the yeah that's still my children's
brother and sisters
no matter what I will always love those
kids yeah yeah but his point is that you
see the problems that came with that
situation and you still picked it so a
lot of times like as women We complain
about situations that we picked and then
we we get what's surprised that like
we're in the the same situation that we
picked
it's like like it's like a guy will
cheat on us when we're dating then we'll
have a kid and then whine about cheating
well then why why do you have a kid
uh so do you expect us to get rid of the
child I'm not I'm not talking about you
guys I'm saying women in general will
pick men that cheat they'll know that
they cheat so oftentimes they'll get
cheated on when they're dating and then
they have a kid together and then whine
about the cheating but he cheated before
so why is it now a problem after you
have children so is that when you're not
the munchies or when you don't know the
munchies
I'm saying like women will go after
entertainers they'll go after rappers
athletes and then get I'm not talking
about you but they'll get shocked that
he cheats and but it's like you went for
that type of guy they'll go for the best
looking guy and then get surprised when
he cheats not even the best looking guys
even if you don't get with them they can
still cheat yeah that one of them and
they cheat they think most women one out
of three men are sexless so one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year you find 20
only 20 percent of men you guys find
attractive 80 of men you find ugly so if
women pick cheaters it's because they go
for a guy that's out of their league
because women that are fours fives and
sixes sleeps with eight nines and tens
maybe get a kid off of him and then he
cheats because they're not on the same
level
oh no I'm not talking about you but I'm
talking I'm talking let me know
I'm not talking about you guys but I'm
saying like women find 80 of men is ugly
most men aren't getting laid like that
so if you're getting cheaters it's
because you pick cheaters
I agree I do
that's my weakness
it's a little adventures
so how is that like his Zimbabwean
culture oh my God
the drink
they drink they don't know how to hold
the job down they have that woman auntie
auntie auntie they're sleeping with
everybody
generalizing their own Nation like once
they work on how much time have you
spent in Zimbabwe
um
like 10 10 years okay you spent 10 years
there yeah you came when you attend here
yeah
and you knew a lot about like cheating
under the age of 10. when I was yeah
when I saw quite a lot that I will not
even bring up
because I'm gonna get done for that
um
I'm not bringing up gossip over here no
I'm gonna do that but
um yeah one even when I went back like I
was asking my grandma about certain
things like relationships and that and
you know because I Was preparing myself
from for marriage for the traditional
marriage and stuff and I was like okay
Grandma like you know if your man is
cheating on you what should you do hey
you have to stay wow if if the man is
beating you but you have to stay I was
like oh wow yes and you know they all
gather like in a group and they're
telling you oh you know you should do
this for your mind you should do this I
was okay so what should the man do for
me they have nothing to say
protecting
um if someone breaks into your house
someone's breaking the house and one of
the one that's gonna go outside to to
beat the person because the man is not
home because it's out here cheating and
drinking
you're saying all the Zim men are
cheating most of this mess if you don't
know about his involvements yet
we have we have that you know my own my
old my older I've had multiple people
work for me though from Zimbabwe there's
a stick
none of them were out there what's
happening right now is that the girls
are spreading the the loudest skills are
spreading this false narrative and
saying that Zimbabwe men are cheating
you just went home to your elders right
and what did they tell you if something
happens you stay you chose not to listen
to advice of your elders so who do you
go for for cancer in your life I've got
nobody that go to council for in my life
I don't think that that's that's uh
anyone who lives on earth needs someone
to go for for guidance if you're just
living your life like this then you know
your actions do reflect I don't think we
can trust your opinion that always
involvement in that trash well you can
ask other women that are not as
important
because I'm sure there's other cultures
though I mean there's no
you guys demonize traditional cultures
when traditional cultures have better
outcomes they have more children they
have happier women they have less STDs
they have less abortions like every
statistical outcome that you can look at
is better from traditional relationships
I agree on the abortion part yeah that
one that's the one I agree with there's
less abortions absolutely but the woman
is suffering from Silence
but that's that's not true no I'm not
saying all I'm saying like there are
some like you know there are some that
do suffer yeah and there's some that you
know the relationships the women in the
western antidepressants they're fat the
average woman's like 165 pounds 170
pounds that's fat
whoa I'm not part of this conversation
it's overweight yeah
well I was gonna say something that was
gonna be really
let me know
they are cool because let's look at our
family Yeah
by law in the celebrator the fairness
if Zimbabwe men are cheating who are
they cheating with
the skinian women
okay so it's the women
right it's the women they're cheating
with the men right why is it the man why
is it not the women
you'd be surprised who they have to be
able to cheat with somebody so why do
you blame the men I blame the men
because of how I was raised like I said
in the beginning you know the way I
think of Zimbabwe men is directly
reflected on how the moment in my life
have treated me and people around me my
other family members that's basically it
yeah
I'm gonna run with that one then you
have to show me different show me
different show me something else
you the way you've been disagreeing with
everything I've said yeah that's a
Zimbabwe man for you it is they will
never understand from another person's
point of view no it's not important it's
not a point of view if you're saying
something that I disagree with then as a
man uh actually as a Zimbabwe Man
actually we don't take women's thoughts
very seriously
wow it sounds like my uncle wow
yeah because you guys act out of emotion
a lot of the time and a lot of you now
westernized that's why a lot of symbol
men are not even marrying Zimbabwean
women anymore
but we're talking about the women that
are back home 25 of men cheat in your
age group
under 30
um and she approximately 10 of the time
and the girls cheat more at
approximately 15 percent
um half of male cheaters only cheat once
they're doing studies and women cheat
more
I'd argue if you if you no I agree Gauss
do cheat right but I just don't
understand why you have this like hatred
towards men that I've told you I have
gone through certain things but you said
you had issues with your stepmom too
yeah but I've had I've gone through
certain things but like there's shitty
men they're shitty women why do only men
get the brunt of it because I've never
been with a woman so I'm gonna talk face
on a man
sorry but I just I don't understand why
there's like this open missandry in
society like if men spoke the way that
women speak about men like it would not
be accepted you hear women say what
women are you you hear women say that
men are trash but you never hear that
women are trash even though we are by
stats if you look at the numbers 90 of
yet 90 of us are on birth control one
out of three of us is had an abortion um
the average women have slept on average
with over like between five to eight and
some studies we'll say between 10 to 15
people which is a [__] ton in all of
history only five percent of women are
virgins on their wedding days when you
look at the things that men look for
which is Purity and youth the average
age of first marriage is 31 we have
women coming into marriages with
children from other men which throughout
all of history was Haram no no is bad
and so women are of lower quality than
ever before and yet they have the most
to complain about but men don't have not
everybody's got that quality too there's
some bombing men out there you're right
there are bummy mad but the difference
is the bummy men aren't delusional you
don't see the bummy man requiring a lot
from women oh oh yeah the the only bummy
men that do are very good looking and
it's because women sleep with them men
cannot live in delusion because they
will not get women
if if if a man has nothing nobody's
going to sleep with him one out of three
men are not sleeping with anybody
and and if and if the and if the women
and if the women are and if the men are
shitty it's do you guys agree with the
phrase men I'll do anything for sex
yes or no yes no okay yes I I think
that's true that men will do anything
for sex and so and so into me if man if
men are acting a certain way it's
because women are rewarding the shitty
men with sex
how how can you like blame the behavior
of the men when you're sleeping with the
cheating men when most men don't cheat
we're having children with men that
cheat
and then we'll complain about the
cheater well if you don't know that
they're cheating yeah listen yes
but did you did you okay did you ask
your parents because parents have more
wisdom than you they know more than you
and they and I'm sorry but you actually
usually usually what happens is women
will bring show the like show the guy to
their parents that cheats the later will
be a cheater the parents both say no not
a good guy not a good guy that women
don't listen
make a child with him and then want to
cry later and say oh I don't how did I
not know when it's like okay he warned
you she warned you you didn't listen
then you made a kid with him and now you
have a big mess
that you chose but I can't call the
children mess anyway but like I wanted
to no I'm not talking about the kids I'm
talking about the situation I wanted to
say yeah you know when you mentioned
about oh my God I forgot now ah can you
repeat what you say the kids because
yeah there's a certain part that she she
said and I wanted to say something about
it
yeah
I said let me let me find this it was no
it was a parent thing when you um you
asked for advice from your parents this
and that and you don't listen and all
that what's hard about listening to your
parents
in a situation like that where if they
say yes or no to a partner it's because
you look at their life more time I look
at someone's life before like I do what
they say so if you're telling me Oh
don't be with that person but you have
been in different marriages you've
broken up without you I'm not gonna take
it seriously
don't they know what not to pick
but they would know what not to pick
right based on the experience wouldn't
you wouldn't you now know what not to
pick for for I don't know if you have a
daughter or a son but now that you you
figured out what didn't work couldn't
you say to your daughter that doesn't
work absolutely this is the problem is
you guys think you're smarter than your
parents I don't think I'm smart I did
not say that but a certain things women
do when they don't listen to them
exactly because you you seem to you said
you didn't listen to your parents
whenever you say that
in terms of their relationship yeah yeah
and so you think yeah so you think
you're smarter than your parents I
didn't think no no no no but there's
some things
right and not saying that I'm smarter
than my mom or my dad I'm not saying
that but maybe we should just give my
mouth shut yeah next
it sounds like you have a lot of like
admiration for your dad me no like I
can't lie to you now my dad has shown me
a different side that I really
appreciate you know after the things
you've gone through
I as a as a child I went back to him and
I said you know Dad I know we went
through a lot of mess
um I'm pregnant I'm sorry you know and
he took me back and everything and since
then he's really like showing me so much
so if you're dead who kicked you out out
of anger pose you probably said
something mad that day for him to do
that did you try to go back and
apologize after they kicked you out
I never went back because he didn't want
me back he told me not to come back so
now if you say that out of anger my
father has never reacted like that to me
before so now imagine you're in a space
where you're thinking you're confused
you're thinking oh my God like what just
happened to me I've gone to college now
because I was the last day of my college
I'm asking my friends I'm telling I'm
like bro I don't know where to go you
didn't but you didn't go back and
apologize I didn't go back on the same
day I did not go back because the way he
never you never apologize I apologize at
the I mean after how many years if he
had gone back and apologized leave it
the next day you would have taken you in
no I believe so no if he came and took
it in and said I forgive you when you
are pregnant
no when I got when I fell pregnant
that's different now and then you came
and he still said now it's all good so
when you're pregnant that was yesterday
or after apparently they're happy that I
was not dead yeah that's what I'm saying
apparently emotion is to take care of
you and they will love you even if you
feel like they don't like you although
they feel like some type of way and I'm
pretty sure that scenario as well
because I've had instances in my family
so where you can get mad and you
apparently be like get out of it from
here you know I mean but you come back
the next day and it's all good but in
that instance they don't want to see you
because you'll probably say something
bad to them yeah but now imagine in a
situation where you your father's never
acted like that before I don't know what
to do yeah but I'm not scared I was
thinking bro if I got back like
I was like no I need to find whatever
else was gonna sleep Austin and sleep
there and it just came in two years and
years and years right and he never even
contacted me he never tried to look for
me and I was trying to come back yeah I
do take responsibility to certain extent
of the things obviously like you know if
I went back ah I don't know how that
would have ended I can't lie to you and
I did not want to find out is your dad a
cheater I don't know
so why are you so adamant to say that's
the Marvel men are cheating because of
my friends I've got somebody who's
loving friends I've got family members
family members I've been cheered on
about are any of your friends married
yeah Zimbabwe man yeah and they and they
say that it's involvements yeah and
they're cheating as well and then the
marriage yeah okay so they're both wow
they're like there's nothing so they're
both cheating they're both cheating and
they're happy and so how are you gonna
blame the men if the women are trying to
the man was cheating first so that's
what everyone with cheese is good it was
gonna blame the next person you know I
mean yeah
how do you know that how do you know
that women be lying a lot I'm pretty
sure you were out with your friend and
they started cheating and you're like
why are you cheating and they're like my
man has been cheating they were fighting
a defense I carry myself with some
specific people for a reason
I don't want to be embarrassed in public
okay yeah yeah thank you I don't
understand I just don't understand how
you can blame the men when the women are
cheating too women lie they'll say they
cheated first but you don't know they
did so you think women lie yes really
women absolutely
three lives yeah yeah
no I've never cheated but no I mean but
but this is the why why are you if
you're gonna do that you can go no you
gotta stop sorry this is but this is the
thing like women women do lie more than
men men own up to [__] even this whole
story you guys are telling like it's
like you're the victim in every single
situation you're in
Not all men own up
some men do yes
more than women
um
well in that part I couldn't agree
because you guys you carry the pain and
you spread it to your kids now you're
gonna walk around and tell your kids
remember women are trash because you're
preaching that gospel right now but but
when you go to your dad it's like oh my
dad is he's a great guy now you guys are
cool but I don't think it's a it's a
productive or even a good statement to
generalize the whole nation and say oh
this is men attraction you guys go on
Twitter because I see a lot of
Zimbabwean girls some you know tweeting
this stuff a lot but it's just a small
minority that's just the loudest saying
Zimbabwe men are cheating and all that
stuff but you guys tend to go for the
Nigerian man uh not saying anything
about that but people also generalize
them as well but I don't believe in
generalizing anybody and I think the
Zimbabwean culture actually is good for
marriages and families all together
because your family if you had actually
came back the next day I appreciate they
would have forgiving you and they're
there to keep the family unit together
did you get divorced from from that from
your stepmom
he said there was one before that how
did that one go she was she was good so
what was this is so what was the
situation I don't know whatever happened
between them happened didn't it and I
really I don't know do you guys do you
guys think that modern women deserve
traditional treatment
um
in what as in what way so do you think
that men should hold the doors pay for
the date
um that sort of thing
I mean the door I can hold mine come on
if you want to be romantic he has to hop
open the door be a romantic person like
like the average the average woman she's
not a virgin right she slept with
multiple men
um she makes money just like the men do
nowadays so like knowing that like do
you think we should go 50 50.
50 50 on the bills at home on the bills
everything everything no no evidence not
everything like what what should we not
go 50 50 on so that makes sense
it doesn't make sense no why no because
I'm I think you just said 50 50 in terms
of relationships right in terms of like
handling the bills oh babe you know go
and get the shopping like understand
that but know why not when you're going
on a date oh yeah because you're 50 50
yeah you have to get your own cup or get
your own Cutlery
can you say 100 I'm talking based on you
I work it I'm working you bring what
you're bringing I bring about bringing
we work together that's what I'm talking
about
would you date a man that's making less
than you
no sorry I would I would I would ruin
him I need someone strong someone that's
really cool I'll be real you have to
make more than me they have to
what type of what type of yearly wage
you're looking to get or have
in a man no comment
hmm but they have to make more than you
you have to make more than me and then
they have to bring all their money 80k
they have to make more than me okay I
don't know what you make but I'm not
going to stay I'm saying what what
income are you looking for in a partner
now come in
okay
you got to answer these questions okay
then you can you can go I'll go okay
I'll happily go okay goodbye bye
foreign
with your friend she can't wait in here
oh she can't wait in here no
are you actually going no if you're not
going to answer the questions that's not
a personal question asking what you make
or not what you make um what you want in
a partner we ask those questions all the
time you staying or going
I would like her to actually stay but
trying to think how can you bring her
back to answer Tav
hold on let me go okay one second oh
so what'd you think of your first
wow
it was it went faster than I thought
[Laughter]
chats for a second
um
[Music]
the other girl can stay the one She's
Gotta Go
um
uh okay I'm gonna Read Super chats guys
make sure you like the video
okay we got a big Super Chat why is she
awarded alimony and child support if she
went to college and got ran through the
whole premise of going to college is
what if he leaves me oh that's a good
point then why did you go to college if
you're just asking for his assets in a
divorce um just go get a job after the
divorce after you divorce or no lazy
who rests something I read Dr David
Black Ops if Zimbabwe and men are
cheating then who are they cheating with
um if the women are not cheating La
thank you for the Super Chat L.A thank
you for the Super Chat Kevin um taquita
a pearl you're looking more and more
feminine keep it up
um
um marriage causes divorce mothers
brainwash their kids with one-sided
gossip marriage causes divorce mothers
should not trauma dump onto the kids um
royco two on the couch y'all don't know
um what you what you two want and you
have three kids this is why families
fail feelings over family and Trauma and
wow really mental abuse yet she was a
rebel and rude W daughter l or W Dad L
daughter chat Ivy um I really want Circa
on your show oh my gosh we want to bring
him out here
um on live when you have your super
annoying regular females on panel uh
named danelva they want Zircon to know
about a panel oh that would be crazy we
can we could bring denalva back uh BB a
red pill dating app
all right let me refresh it really quick
um
why so why do you think like what what's
with the second generation zimbabweans
like why do they have this negative
picture of Zimbabwe like because you
grew up in Zimbabwe yeah grew up in
Zimbabwe yeah I think it's just you know
the
the Western the westernized ones
especially the girls they have like a
lot of Parental issues I think when you
come to the Western world it's a bit
more liberal here than Zimbabwe where
more for like a conservative Nation you
know what the parent says goes
good all of that so when they come over
here and they start getting all these
ideas like oh I can think for myself and
I can do all this stuff
they they don't have a respect photo
yeah it just gets crazy after that
now it's so interesting because it's
like you're leaving a culture where like
fam like family I mean I don't know much
about the stats from Zimbabwe in
particular but it seems like families
just from talking to you like family's
super important there and it's like
we'll leave a culture that worked and go
to a culture that's for families anyway
worse but it's like it's like they'll
[__] on it later and it's so weird to me
yeah now grandmothers understood that
you heard herself like when she went to
Zimbabwe and they're asking all these
questions the old base so they'll be
like you know you have to you have to
stay if anything goes wrong in the
marriage you have to stay if anything
goes wrong in this you have to stay
because they understand that the
importance of family as well but as much
as you know we would like that to happen
as well there was a must like Exodus
from Zimbabwe because of our financial
situation so a lot of people left
Zimbabwe and went to Canada UK you were
saying all of that so there's a lot of
like second generation zimbabweans that
are westerners so yeah the relationship
Dynamic right now it's a bit crazy
would you I didn't even get to the point
of the show
I broke it guys I broke them I broke
Twitter the other day I was beefing I
was beefing um
I freaking
tweeted the other day
uh something that broke Twitter it's
gonna get like 10 million views I think
it's on track to get
because I tweeted
I tweeted let me ask my wife with like a
barfing emoji
and the reason I tweeted this a lot of
people you know
didn't understand why I tweeted this is
I had I had this Epiphany the other day
that we don't really have traditional
relationships anymore because even in
the more traditional relationships on
paper
the woman still runs it because the man
is constantly doing what the woman wants
because they don't want her to freak out
and men just want like what's easy and
they're like I'll just go with what she
wants and I realized like a lot of men
when they want to make a decision
they'll say let me ask my wife and it's
not in a way like I want to consult her
and I was thinking of like a boss like
employee relationship and I'm like a
boss wouldn't go to his
Superior and say or what's it Superior
below you Superior yeah
and say like you I need you to make this
decision for me
so that's what I was thinking of like
wait but as inferior and ask for their
permission they might ask for
information but there's a difference
between information and permission and
this erupted the internet everyone's
like I ask my wife for things and I'm
like there's a difference between asking
for information and asking for her
permission
yeah that's like a modern perspective
now that people have like let me ask my
wife for things you know
um you know you know I know Mike I was
watching this gonna get in trouble I
don't care
sorry uh but there's a thing of like
um I think it's like infected the
society in general now like if you see
all the TV movies you see like like the
dramas whatever's like the wife is like
the smaller one the husband is a dumb
one everything goes wrong the husband
has to go to like the the wife like
Simpsons like that's a cartoon so it's
programming people from Young from young
age that as much as you happy wife happy
life from a young age you're just gonna
think that your wife is gonna be smarter
than you uh so I think that's you know I
think you can ask for information yeah
but when they ask for permission it's a
bit more
it's not godly as a Christian mind I
don't I don't think that's Godly and I'm
so tired of hearing Christians say we
have to submit to each other like you
guys are supposed to submit to each
other no they take one verse out of
context that says that give each other
to yourself when it's talking about
giving your body like your body doesn't
belong to you it belongs to your wife or
your wife's body doesn't belong to you
it belongs to the husband and that's the
verse that people take in terms of
submitting each other but the Bible says
that uh the husband is the head of the
family just as Christ is the head of the
church so as the head that means that
you are the decision maker so people
want to Pivot towards that verse that's
a bit more of a liberal kind of approach
to it to say that because this verse
says that I should give my body to my
wife that means that we need to submit
to each other but that's not the case
well and I started thinking about other
things right like I saw can we play the
the pastor one that blessing you sent
this to me but I started thinking about
other things in context of like an
employee employ like in employer
employee relationship and I was thinking
about arguments and I'm like
if they're arguing like that's that's a
sign that the like you wouldn't argue
with your boss you just say okay but
like women are not taught to say okay
they're taught to like question
everything
yeah that happens a lot now especially
in this modern societies
we can watch this then we can all go
home yeah yeah
been a long day thank you Chad for being
nice to me yeah yeah I'm scared of these
people it's crazy
or um if every man and Every Woman
married at 30 companies would go
bankrupt uh fashion surgery Fitness
online dating companies push push the
narrative that women can have it all
keep um keep them spending and consuming
let's go into female pastors
laughs
oh wait please
play this how are you gonna play is it
there
it is so hot in here
and let's say
one of the words that was spoken was
spoken by my husband while is we were
arguing
I said number one why were you arguing
with your husband
according to calling this position
then the man goes like what are you
saying you you think we are at the same
level here and then arguments ensue so
arguments should never be there because
there should not be an argument why
because there is nobody we should be
arguing with the leader of the House
[Applause]
to God you follow God's plan
the fact that women spend 80 percent of
the time it's like unbiblical when you
think about it because that means she's
in charge of the finances in the house
but she's not supposed to be making the
decisions it's supposed to be the guy
yeah it's meant to be the man really
that's why even
um if you look in the Bible the Bible is
quite right on the on the low of these
things but you know as feminism getting
distraction he infrared to the church as
well so you get a lot of like a lot of
things that bring a lot of equality in
the Bible in terms of like women
um but
not to say that you know women don't
have a place but their place is just no
leadership
right yeah and and you know I know a lot
of Christians are gonna be beefing me on
this one but
and I go to a church that has female
pastors
by me how do you feel about female
well
in a way it's not I mean
I haven't done too much studies but I
don't think it's biblical to have female
pastors right but at the same time as
well it's not really like I can leave my
church because I
owner of my father and my mother and
this is the church that I was raised on
so I'm not going to become too Western I
see the point where I'm just like just
because I'm not telling you to leave
your church I'm asking what you think
about the pastors
are you thinking about it is that what
comes to your head you're bringing it up
you know when you become an adult you
have to make a decision for yourself
sometimes you know
um but I think it's a decision that you
make when you get married because when
you get married the Bible says you live
your father and your mother and you join
with your wife and become one and I
think that's when you can make a
decision of where your family is going
because now you are now the head of the
family but it's not as I stand as a
single person I'm not the head of family
I'm still in submission to the authority
in my family because I can't leave the
family yet
so people get that room you know when
people leave their family
um religion or ideology sometimes I have
I have a bit of disagreement with that
because
um
you know didn't like Christianity come
to Africa didn't like someone have to
have left their families yeah yeah yeah
Christian was bought by this so should
you be whatever
the traditional one yeah like whatever
was before that like were they wrong
um because the way I was raised I was
raised Christian already I don't think
they are wrong I'm I'm full African
tradition it was there before me yeah
and I think you know if you are
fortunate enough to have that culture in
your family embrace it it's just not my
my experience here no I was just
wondering if you thought the same thing
like because I just thought Christianity
came to Africa it did yeah it's not
really original but again again is there
is also the Ethiopian Orthodoxy church
so
um days these conspiracies about this
whether Christianity was
introduced to Africa or reintroduced to
Africa it was already in Africa so yeah
he's do you agree this
yeah Christianity was in Africa before
it was reintroduced yeah oh I don't know
so you might yeah I just thought it came
from like Europe that's what I thought
um I don't know much about it though
yeah it's a reintroduction back into
Africa before that he came through the
Ethiopian eunuch in the Bible uh who
received who got baptized by Philip so I
say yes dog MPI says what what the girl
was saying about Zimbabwe man is that
how it sounded exactly like what
American black women say about black men
the missandry is so real these women are
single mothers of sons they're raising
their boys to be criminals
uh and then ten dollars when a man gets
married in the west power dynamics and
the relationship shifts to the woman
because the man knows she can leave any
time with half of his net worth and the
kids
okay Douglas Doug is right there that
one wasn't dog oh no I mean the first
one yeah oh yeah yeah
okay guys you guys want to go home yeah
yeah we're tired
um okay guys
um like the video on your way out
um thank you to that girl for getting
kicked out so I can end this show early
today yeah
um also guys
um I think mizzy is coming on Monday I'm
not sure but I I think he's supposed to
come on Monday yeah
right Ellen is that
um like the video on your way out guys
before you enter I just want to say this
is not a fair representation of
Zimbabwean girls I know she does that to
us Zimbabwean guys but there are some
Zimbabwean girls that are not like this
out there so that they don't beef me
later on
um okay guys like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel
depend on religious beliefs it is
everything to do with having a good
attitude realistic expectations and a
good relationship skills all right
thanks guys like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King Richie is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's video channel to
Jenny's podcast it's your boy The Fresh
Prince of someone yeah but I've been
coffee free for four months okay I gotta
say that how could everyone have someone
out there for them when there's more
women than men like I'm not saying you
have to be submissive to every old waste
man walking around I'm just saying that
it would be femininity would be in your
nature breaking it is to find somebody
you're compatible with that you'd like
not just of your same generation and
that likes the same things that you do
going out having fun get out okay okay
then then get out then get out after
after then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taken care of
taking care of I'm ladylike I'm
submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm going to look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
so bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
[Music]
[Applause]